on se demande ce soir si dans le
contexte actuel il faudrait revenir à la
nationalisation d'air canada a des
couilles zabel dostaler qui est doyenne
de la faculté de l'administration des
affaires à l'université mémorial de
terre-neuve bonsoir isabelle dostaler
bons soins air canada qui a annoncé
vingt mille suppressions d'emplois on
sait que ça va changer là pour le monde
aérien est ce qu'on devrait repenser à
nationaliser de nouveau air canada
quelle grande question un psy sûr que
c'est une question qui revient quand les
choses ont moins bien on s'est toujours
la question de privatiser les profits de
nationaliser les pertes
cette récente de à quel point beaucoup
plusieurs commentateurs ou plusieurs
personnes sont d'avis que la meilleure
façon de structurer une épicerie que le
maire modèles possibles pour le
transport aérien
c'est la privatisation se souvient c'est
un grand mouvement qui est arrivé à la
fin des années soixante dix et si on
avait vraiment l'impression que c'est
c'était la façon de faire mais quand on
regarde ça moi ma ma théorie c'est que
les transporteurs aériens aime pas
vraiment la concurrence et s'organise
toujours pour pouvoir avoir entre eux d
entente tacite qui sont jamais au
bénéfice du consommateur
c'est son garde les trois grandes
alliances aériennes
au fond ces trois oligopole trois
monopoles dans son jeu contre un
monopole cotées en bourse
une entreprise des temps où un monopole
d'état pardon c'est à se demander
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui serait lui
alors c'est certainement
c'est une question qui se pose ça
m'étonnerait qu'on se rend jusque là
c'est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer une
semi privé d'une semi nationalisation ou
le gouvernement pourrait investir en et
chance en échange deux sièges au conseil
d'administration
et il notamment
il ya fort à parier que ça empêcherait
les salaires faramineux qu'on paye dans
ce genre de grandes entreprises quand
les choses vont bien donc tous à
considérer mais il s'agira de voir
comment les choses évoluent tu parce que
l'on se pose des questions sur l'avenir
d'air canada sur le sur le modèle
d'affaires de toutes façons de toutes
les compagnies aériennes mais si cette
entreprise là est moins grande si elle a
des problèmes financiers le pourrait
encore se placer sous la protection des
tribunaux
les avions cloués au sol en ce moment là
c'est des pertes monstrueuse bruère
canada c'est énorme c'est quand on pense
à ses passagers qui voulaient récupérer
leur argent plutôt que d'avoir des
crédits pour des voyages futur où air
canada va t elle prendre cet argent
c'est énorme et la crise était non plus
et pas seulement à canada en difficulté
financière comme autant de deux
lorsqu'elle s'était mise sous la
protection des tribunaux
c'est vraiment tout tout le système de
transport aérien c'est un peu notre mode
de vie en sait il faudrait décider
ce serait intéressant de voir comment
seront nous par la suite c'est ce qu'on
va devenir très sédentaire ou est-ce
qu'on va redevenir nomades assez
rapidement dès qu'un vaccin existe c'est
ce qu'on voit est ce qu'on va oublier
cette crise ou est-ce que notre notre
monde va changer pour de bon et si on
parle de plusieurs années avant un
retour à la normale c'est à se demander
ce qui peut arriver imaginer et je pense
notamment notamment à tous ces avions
qui sont commandés l'achat d'avions est
un processus très long on passe une
commande qui a plusieurs années avant de
prendre livraison d'un appareil qu'on a
commandée qu'est ce qui va arriver le
jour ces avions lots seront seront prêts
à être livrés s'il n'y a pas de demande
si les activités sont réduites de plus
de 90% c'est vraiment à c'est vraiment
énorme et skate canada à votre avis sur
nationalise paes qu'air canada quand
même besoin d'emprunter de l'argent à
l'état et de l'aide de l'état
oui sûrement de l'aide de l'état
évidemment donc comment ont-elles hilal
qu'elle est là
la solution qui est la plus avantageuse
pour le public voyageur le peuple
canadien c'est parce que la
nationalisation dans un dans un pays
comme le nôtre quand on y pense on fond
serait finalement un assez bon candidat
pour ça parce que c'est très difficile
avec le modèle de l'entreprise privée de
l'entreprise cotée en bourse d'assurer
le droit au transport dans les régions
éloignées on est un pays at-elle faible
densité de la population et la
privatisation du transport aérien n'a
pas tellement bien servi les régions moi
je me rappelle avoir une conversation
avec le pdg d'air canada câlin dra 10
inscrits qui était venu donc par là nos
étudiants puis bon je vais poser la
question est ce que le canada a une
responsabilité par rapport au
développement régional et sa réponse
était catégorique non elkann adonne avec
une aucune responsabilité envers ses
actionnaires alors jusqu'à quel point le
modèle de l'entreprise cotée en bourse
il ce qui sert le mieux
un pays comme le nôtre backs il faut
peut-être la regarder d'un peu plus près
cette question de la nationalisation
dernier point que vous l'avez un peu
abordé le npd le bloc québécois option
consommateurs demande que les billets
soient remboursés est-ce que c'est
approprié de demander ça en ce moment
dans les circonstances aux compagnies
aériennes
mais c'est sûr que si eux on est dans la
peau du public voyageur de la personne
qui ne peut voyager qui n'a pas pu
voyager une pensera pouvant voyager en
dans les deux prochaines années
c'est sûr que cette personne n'en veut
récupérer devrait récupérer son bien
mais on prend cet argent là où la crise
des liquidités en ce moment est énorme
c'est vraiment vraiment pas une
situation facile ceci dit c'est pas si
c'est pas une question de prendre pour
un ou deux prendre pour eux c'est une
situation excessivement difficile
exactement merci beaucoup pour cette
réflexion isabelle dostaler ce soir
merci ça m'a fait plaisir